lunch money today is brought to you by
ftx ftx happens to be one of if not the
best
cryptocurrency exchange i guess is the
way to talk about them right yep that's
right all right just kidding uh ftx is a
u.s regulated crypto exchange and one of
the largest exchanges in the united
states they're rapidly growing to use
uh to a user base with millions of users
they have a couple of key features that
you need to know about the first is that
they have the ftx app it's a zero fee
trading app for top cryptocurrencies
stocks are coming and nfts with no gas
fees
ftx.us is up to 85 cheaper than top
competitors trading platform to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies and of course the
most complete crypto and finance app
that allows users to buy and sell crypto
stocks in the near future and nfts now
here's the key pieces not only do they
have all the crypto and they have very
very cheap fees but on top of that they
are bringing the digital stocks where
there's no trading fees and no payment
for order flow it's gonna be pretty cool
so go check them out if you go and you
sign up today it will give you some
rewards for going and doing it if you
don't want the rewards do it because you
like us support us by supporting them go
to ftx
just drop the link in the chat go get
that all right polina what do we got
today to get started all right let's
talk about the i like your shirt by the
way
thank you that's not what you said last
time i wore it well he looks like a
peacock there now you don't
that's what he said last time
okay so russia thinks do you remember
that one shirt i had and you said it
looked like what's going on from the 70s
and then i never wore it again
russia thinks it has found a way around
washington's dollar bond payment
blockade so apparently russia is trying
out new ways to kind of circumvent u.s
sanctions this is fake news wait why
because because uh what they're trying
to do is paying rubles yes which is not
a way around the sanction it's the u.s
can't stop people from using rubles
because they don't control the rubles no
but they're trying to pay their external
debts using rubles yeah well what else
are they gonna do so the way to think
about this is russia has a bunch of
bondholders that are outstanding and uh
they owe them interest and if they don't
pay the interest that means they're
defaulting on that debt and so that'd be
really bad this be one of the larger
economies to to ever do that uh and so
instead uh with the u.s when they
leveled all the sanctions back in
february they had an exemption the
exemption was hey there's sanctions on
russia except you can use us dollars to
pay your foreign bond holders now as of
i think it's may 25th i remember
correctly uh they have allowed that
exemption to expire meaning that there
are now sanctions russia cannot pay
their foreign bondholders using us
dollars so what does russia do well they
say hey we're trying to pay you guys but
we can't because we can't use dollars
get mad at them but in the meantime they
moved a bunch of money things like 100
million dollars or something over into
uh their domestic uh clearing house and
they said hey we have the money the
money's sitting there we're trying to
pay it to you guys but they won't let us
pay it in dollars so guess what open up
a ruble account with us and then we'll
pay you in rubles if you don't open up
the ruble account your money's sitting
there but i can't give it to you because
these people won't let me do it the
bigger thing ends up being in a very
very very serious situation that they
also owe about 2 billion
by the end of the year and so it's not
just 100 million it could be yes is this
not a perfect
use case for something like bitcoin
what
are you orange pilling people right now
no i'm just asking yes of course duh
everyone used to run around the world
and be like we like dollars we like
dollars we like dollars
the u.s dollar is now dependent on
whether the united states likes you or
not
yeah and there's a lot of countries that
say hey me in the u.s we're boys right
now yeah we we chill you know we on
friday night we go grab some beers
but maybe one day we're not going to be
chill maybe we're not going to be cool
maybe
i don't want to actually have 100
dependence on a foreign currency where
the government can just snap their
fingers and basically kick me out global
financial system right i don't think
that the united states
was trying to solve the long-term
problem when they made this decision
they were trying to mitigate the
short-term problem which is russia
invaded ukraine
they didn't want to go to war which i
also agree with but what else can they
do they don't really have that many
things that they can do so they sanction
the [ __ ] out of russia
but in doing so they basically revealed
the financial sanction playbook to the
world and now people are absolutely
saying hold on a second i cannot be
dependent on a us dollar denominated
financial system if this is the playbook
that they are going to move uh towards
in the future yeah so when you don't
trust each other why not use a
decentralized digital currency that no
one controls
okay let the peacock speak
um
so
we got elon musk
so elon musk is like i don't know what
is going on with him and twitter right
now he is accusing them of trying to of
resisting and thwarting his right to
information about fake accounts on the
platform uh calling it a clear material
breach
a lawyer on his behalf sent a letter
that said mr musk reserves all rights
resulting there from including his right
not to consummate the transaction in his
right to terminate the merger agreement
so in other words because isn't there
like a billion dollar breakup fee or
something so is this kind of like him
putting it all out there being like hey
i want to close this deal but they're
thwarting my attempts at figuring out
what's do you think they're thwarting
his attempts
um i don't know i have no doubt they're
thwarting his attempts why because he
knows exactly what everyone else on the
platform knows you gotta be on twitter
for like 30 seconds and realize that
more than five percent of the accounts
are bots well we don't know if you're
telling no i 100 percent now 100 there's
not very many things in life that are
100
bots on twitter being more than 5 is a
hundred percent
why
i can tweet and literally what happens
box box box spot spots there's probably
more bots that respond than actual
people they're probably more bought
anthony's than actual anthony well
there's definitely more body in place
than anthony just check the comments and
so naturally if elon is saying
give me the data and they give him the
data and he says okay now give me the
testing data whatever he's asking for if
it is negative
they don't want to give it to a question
i have a question when you buy a company
at this scale are you allowed to get all
the information that you need
if you buy a company for 40 billion
dollars you may go to the ceo's house
and ask him what his toenail clipper
brand is
you get it you get whatever information
you want oh i do not like that
well then you don't get that your
company bought for 40 billion dollars it
doesn't matter you go and you say hey
how much money are we spending on water
you get to show up and say hey what is
the person who used to work here what is
the legal situation anything and
everything possible that you can get
that is available you have access to
you're buying the company you're doing
due diligence and something as simple as
proof to me that your user base is real
isn't the equivalent of going to the
ceo's house and asking personal
information it's like the first thing
that somebody's gonna ask for yeah
and the fact that they don't want to
give it to him tells you everything you
need to know it's like when you find a
little kid remember when you're like a
little kid and your parents come in the
room and they're like uh what are you
doing you're like nothing what were you
doing it's something that i wasn't
supposed to do or i would have just told
them and the second you're like nothing
they're like
they start asking more questions that's
what this is is elon's like give me the
data and they're like
and he's like i got more questions one
time i skipped school to read a book
well what's the next like i feel sick i
wasn't actually sick what's the next um
okay
so
bitcoin miners are beginning to sell
tokens that they've hoarded to cover
costs with the prospects for industry
growth slo this is a words out you're
you're such a nerd why
because you skipped school to read a
book all right so uh with bitcoin miners
basically what happens is they mine
their revenue is denominated in bitcoin
so they mine bitcoin they put on their
balance sheet in good times as the price
of bitcoin goes up that means their
balance sheet is expanding everything is
good in the world amazing but
in reverse what happens is when the
price is going down their balance sheets
are contracting as their balance sheets
are contracting they still have dollar
denominated uh expenses so they have to
pay their staff they have to pay their
vendors their energy costs etc and so
naturally some of them say hey you know
what we don't want to sell all the
bitcoin on our balance sheet but we need
to have some cash maybe we should sell i
don't know five percent ten percent of
the bitcoin we have to get cash so that
we're able to then go ahead and pay for
whatever our expenses end up being makes
sense yeah
you don't seem very interesting sorry i
just got a call that's weird okay okay
all right so um today
uh is wwe no wwdc it's not wrestling
it's wwdc
it's apple's event
so what's interesting i i scoured all
the announcements they could possibly
make the one that i think is really
interesting is they might announce a
long rumored ar vr headset dumb do you
remember when you got the oculus it's
still in the box
dumb yeah
um it ain't happening it ain't happening
why they all keep saying this nobody's
putting a box on their face what do you
mean
nobody is putting a box on their face
and walking around like we're all
aardvarks
artworks have nothing to do with them
yeah it is don't bring them do you know
what aardvark looks like arthur
yeah they have like what looks like a
box on their face not over his eyes but
yeah it's got a little boxy shape to it
that's a nose that's a snout
whatever okay whatever um anyway so so
it could there could be a headset
but
they've been teasing it for so long we
don't know
yeah they could also have a car they
could have this they could have that
whatever let's see
do you know what i was thinking when i
was by the way i have like
i'm i'm so deep into the apple ecosystem
they own me well you know what i was
thinking
uh as i the people know that i recently
got a printer and i've been printing uh
but you know what i thought about jerome
powell style
but do you know what i thought about why
doesn't apple create a printer because
it's 2022 and who the [ __ ] needs a
printer
so many people actually if you can
create a printer for photos even better
okay what's next well i'm just i'm just
giving them ideas for their www apple
we're bringing us back to 1970.
i have a lot of things to print all
right next
next so outer space is getting crowded
so do you remember how
do you remember how there's a u.s space
force that was created they now want to
police the outer space that actually
sounds like very intelligent wait why
because because people there's no rules
up there and they're probably start
slinging all kinds of nonsense well
people are slinging all sorts of
satellites up there exactly exactly well
so now so now you need rules
but who gets to decide those rules
whoever's got the most uh superiority in
the fire space of space
what does that mean
well
if you end up controlling it's like it's
like on the road if you think in the
road right now
if you think on the road right now who
gets to make the rules the people with
the guns in space the road yeah the
police oh oh they enforce the rules
right the the government they got a
monopoly on violence they got to make
the rules in space same thing whoever's
got the most dominance they're going to
make the rules the elon musk
no
space force
they'll shoot the [ __ ] out of a spacex
satellite in a heartbeat if they had to
they don't want to they they like it but
like if they got to enforce stuff where
they going to pull over the satellite
like oh dude they're going to punish
people here on earth obviously well this
major general sean branton said we've
been collaborating with private industry
for years now and certainly we increase
that activity as the presence of
commercial industry increases in space
so we're going to have government in
space too
the government's already in space
what do you think the iss is they have
rules
you can't just you can't just create a
rocket and show up and unannounced are
you know sure i'm 100 positive you can't
show up unannounced to the iss they
won't open the door no i mean like
you can shoot a satellite up there
who's shooting satellites up there
without uh
without some sort of approval you don't
know what i do on my personal time you
couldn't even release a balloon into
space if you tried
i've done that before guys i'm not
supposed to say that that's bad for the
environment
oh come on no yeah i'm i'm esg woke now
we should we should ban balloons
it's bad for the environment have you
ever done the helium thing where your
voice sounds crazy
no because your voice already sounds
crazy
all right so
are we out of time what time no go ahead
you have one more thing no i don't yeah
ask lunch
it's not so much funny time guys please
ask your question in the comments so i
can answer it live because he's going to
kill my section
and then i have to offer jokes instead
you don't have a question um not as of
the moment i have a question for you
very quickly we have
47 seconds
um
miami flooded this weekend brickell
flooded what did you think had a canoe
wait what did you do
yeah
well you saw the videos what did you
think yeah there are some there's some
serious club goers in miami
that's exactly what my reaction was the
shirts were off the pants were off they
were floating they were getting to that
club
no they were getting home from the club
they walked out at like two o'clock in
the morning and it was it was flooded
not they on the way to the club oh i
thought they were determined to get to
that club
anyway
people don't like my jokes farmer george
come on man
come on he said not the jokes run
i have great jokes don't make me do one
right now you do all right
you want to know the joke
what the ask lunch money segment
it's not funny
it's literally anti-fun all right i
appreciate it thank you very much uh
tim hold on what is this tim smigg said
why is anthony such a jerk to you hey
tim
put a sock in it no if you think about
uh one of the things that uh i enjoy i
am a first class world-class [ __ ] talker
plane and i talk [ __ ] to each other all
the time me and my brothers talk [ __ ] to
each other all the time me and ranger
ranger rangers heads in a blender when
i'm talking [ __ ] to him sophia
you all better be careful when she can
talk
y'all gonna be crying that's what's
gonna do also uh just before i go can
you tell who's been sitting by the pool
look at my face look at your face sorry
i like the sun
see ya
bye see you tomorrow hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time